serris bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
alors le rythme des contaminations ne
faiblit pas tout comme les admission en
soins critiques l'hôpital va-t-il
supporter cette cinquième vague selon
vous
alors clairement à l'hôpital est déjà en
difficulté avec les patients qui
viennent pour les pathologies
habituelles donc effectivement on n'a
absolument pas les ressources pour
pouvoir encaisser une vague
supplémentaire de contamination c'est
une certitude quel profil on les
patients qui sont en soins critiques
est ce que ce sont des personnes qui
n'ont qui sont vaccinés qui n'ont pas
reçu de vaccin
alors la réalité scientifique elle et
que effectivement ce sont des
essentielle ment des personnes qui ne
sont pas vaccinés
on voit que la vague omicron fait fait
beaucoup de ravages on parle d'un
variant qui est beaucoup plus contagieux
moins dangereux c'est ce que vous
observez exact également dans les
hôpitaux
oui donc effectivement il ya une moindre
dangerosité qui est liée à la pression
vaccinale parce qu'une majorité de
français qui sont vaccinées donc ça
c'est une certitude et le lien il est
factuel par contre on remarque
effectivement une grande propagation
dans la population de plus jeunes chez
les enfants notamment avec forcément
plus de formes un peu plus sévère que ce
qu'on avait vu jusqu'ici chez les
enfants
les tests justement je voudrais que
qu'on en parle un petit peu puisque
aujourd'hui il ya 2
un nouveau protocole sanitaire qui
concerne notamment les enfants à l'école
qui vont devoir subir plusieurs tests au
cas où il y aurait des cas positifs dans
leur classe
on parle d'une explosion des chiffres
quand on voit le nombre de
contaminations plus de 300000
contamination est ce que c'est dû
justement à ce nombre de tests que l'on
pratique aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
qu'avant
non c'est plutôt lié à la pression
épidémie qui a une grande une grande
diffusion du virus avec ce nouveau
variant clairement c'est c'est plutôt
une pression épidémique qu'un biais lié
à une augmentation du nombre de tests
il ya encore des milliers de personnes
ont manifesté contre les mesures
sanitaires notamment le projet de passes
vaccinale qui est actuellement débattu
au parlement est ce qu'aujourd'hui
ce pass vaccinale est peut-être une des
meilleures manières pour enrayer la
pandémie
on reste quand même toujours sur une
prime c'est quand même toujours mieux de
faire de la pédagogie et de confronter
effectivement au principe de réalité qui
est
finalement qu on se rend bien compte que
la vaccination est efficace non ça c'est
de toute façon quelque chose à quoi on
s'attendait à ce qu'on espérait parce
qu'effectivement avoir un vaccin
efficace en si peu de temps c'est une
chance on reste aussi sur une
problématique de pays riches c'est à
dire qu'il ya quand même une grande
partie de la planète qui n'a pas accès
au vaccin et qui meurent encore à ce
jour donc là dessus ça reste quand même
une certitude je pense qu'il faut rester
sur ces faits là et les diffuser le plus
largement possible
après il ya quand même une
responsabilité de l'état concernant la
protection des concitoyens sans rentrer
dans les débats des mots employés
c'est certes certains qui va de toute
façon qu'il faut qu'ils aient une une
action de l'état pour rendre le plus
large possible
l'adhésion au vaccin ça c'est certain
une action de l'état et ce qu'il faut
aussi passer par l' obligation tout
court de du vaccin finalement au lieu de
voilà de proposer un pass vaccinale et
et mettre de côté une certaine partie de
la population
on reste sur une minorité de français
qui sont à ce jour non vaccinés des
mesures coercitives forte ça peut
toujours quand même malgré tout
donner des crispations la crise et gilet
jaune n'est pas loin envoyer les
personnes qui qui témoignait tout à
l'heure
je pense quand même que la pédagogie et
montrer l'efficacité et les faits c'est
à dire que il ya une forte pression en
réanimation sur des malades qui sont
essentiellement non vaccinés c'est des
éléments qui sont vraiment un privilégié
après de toute façon c'est bien entendu
il faut qu'on fasse unité autour des
décisions qui sont prises au niveau de
l'état est clairement on ne peut pas se
passer d'une certaine pression de la
part de l'état pour protéger les
concitoyens et le pass vaccinale
vraisemblablement c'est un des moyens
qui est probablement le moins mauvais la
dernière question à concernant le
personnel soignant qui est mobilisée
depuis le début de cette pandémie dans
certains hôpitaux manquent de bras
justement pour pour ces malades est ce
que c'est un phénomène que vous observez
également vous même qui est sur le
terrain
parfaitement il ya environ 15 à 20 % de
lits d'hospitalisation actuellement qui
sont fermées dans les hôpitaux publics
en france par manque de soignants et
c'était déjà avant la vague micron donc
c'est pas en lien avec l'impression
épidémique c'est vraiment plus tôt en
lien avec
cibler les politiques de santé et les
mesures qui n'ont pas été prises
notamment lors du choc du ségur qui a
été extrêmement décevant les
augmentations de l'île n'ont pas été au
rendez vous les augmentations
d'effectifs cibles n'ont pas été
effectués et les augmentations de
salaires n'ont absolument pas été en
rapport avec les besoins on est quand
même toujours que la 10e 18e place au
niveau des pays de l' ocde pour
rémunérer nos infirmières ce qui est
largement insuffisant pour la france
merci beaucoup et emmanuelle lassalle et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes porte parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes